[Musique]
non bon à picot ne fumait pas ne fumait
pas sa coupe l'appétit mais pas comme ça
je sors revenus nous ça y est je reviens
naturellement il a pris son couteau il
coûte quelque chose qui vous a fait
couper les cheveux
elles se sont fait couper les cheveux
c'était une chanson ça qu'est ce que
vous proposez à nos jeunes amis et bien
je vais leur proposer un plat très
consistant pour les jours où on a très
faim en venant du bas ce sont des
nouilles sautées du campeur portant les
pas de nouilles en principe il aime pas
ça amène à aller voir d'abord si oui
pourquoi les enfants n'aiment pas
beaucoup les nouilles
mais c'est pourtant l'excellent super
dont six sont pas un camping s'ils sont
chez eux sous la campagne simplement ils
peuvent faire cette recette a bien sûr
monsieur alors là je crois que dans le
camping je vous l'expliqué je vous le
dis et je voulais redit qu' il est très
important qu'il est très important de
faire des plats très consistant on fait
un plan ne fait pas la cuisine est
entrée un plat
alors là je crois que c'est très
important et je voudrais tout de même
vous en parler alors vous savez que
c'est très envié tard et qu'ils n'ont
cependant eu lieu sur la cuisse et
reggae au compteur mais cette règle si
on fait des choses amusantes
il est très embêtante faire la cuisine
c'est à l'aide et à temps même en
vacances alors et où jamais un tout
petit peu d'huile
j'ai mis du beurre elle est blessée puis
bon alors je vais vous parler de sa
soeur champignons de quoi se joue bien
de paris j'obtiendrai il est bien
évident que si il y à des champignons
sylvestres s'il y a des girolles s'il y
a des trompettes de la mort c'est lily à
retomber dans la mort c'est très très
bon alors vrai ou c'est pas venir non
vinet le nez ne sais que ça ça ce sont
des nuits alors oui elles sont cuites
très peu enfin c'est à dire très bien
parce que oui il faut que tout même
voyez vous que les new york 8 juste le
temps nécessaire mais alors le jour ont
vécu à des nouilles
on peut en mettre une certaine quantité
en réserve et en avoir pour le
surlendemain présentable pour tout six à
quatre photos tout
vacances mais on peut tout de même en
faire cuire pour deux fois en tout cas
et ça c'est très important je voudrais
le préciser car ça on sait qu'on s'a une
importante
alors on les conserve dans le petit
réfrigérateur de camping que nous avons
tous elle va et c'est très amusant j'ai
perdu oui moi on est sorti est à
l'extérieur nettoyer alors alors
regardez je vais saler légèrement ses
champignons et l'eau qu'est l'eau à noël
c'est le seul absorbe très vite je vais
ajouter un tout petit peu de beurre
parce que c'est alors là je vais vous
expliquer tout de même comment il faut
faire accuser les nôtres il faut les
faire cuire dans beaucoup d'eau pendant
sept minutes environ cette mini eau
salée les égoutter et surtout ne pas les
races religions surtout surtout ne pas
faire tous les deux fois dessus les
mettre dans un récipient quelconque de
ce style là et y mettre de l'huile une
goutte d'huile
mélanger cette huile de face à ce que
les noms une colle plus ensemble et ça
c'est très important
et après ça on peut les laisser on peut
le laisser pendant plusieurs jours mais
si vous n'avez pas eu la précaution de
mélanger l'huile
aussitôt après quand elle et nous ils
sont encore guéri il faut s'en tienne à
l'école et ce n'est pas très très ni
très beaux ni très joli ventre etc a
donné alors voilà voyez-vous ici
maintenant je vais ajouter des noms en
quantité suffisante pas trop soit la
nécessaire et suffisante
je vais les mélanger comme vous le voyez
avec des champignons
j'ai eu un petit extinction de voix
c'est le grand air sur le ventre il a
fait durant ces jours ci si vous êtes
allez vous baigner
et oui il faisait pas chaud c'est vrai
alors là est dévoyée
ça y est alors je mélange tout ça alors
l'envoyé y en a pour deux fois au moins
et ceci pour deux à trois personnes
nous allons juger que ça vaut pour deux
ou trois personnes la hausse est assez
c'est vraiment le moi moi j'adore ce
genre de cuisine plutôt que c'est très
très bon alors ici regardez catherine ce
que je vais faire je m'en vais pratiquer
des alvéoles comme ceux ci les alvéoles
des arrestations
voyez gens pratiquent une danse est
enlevée roll je vais mettre tout petit
peu de beurre oui encore jusqu'à ce
qu'ils trouvent vous avez fait je vais
casser un oeuf un sens là je vais
continuer je fais une seconde à lever or
ici voyez que les douze de ses tares
bien là puis je vais casser ainsi mon
teint alors là le beurre et ce dix ans
j'aurais vu que le fonds ne m'a pas
l'été sec tout à l'heure c'est pourquoi
je ajouter là et puis ainsi de suite tu
veux faire une alvéole
pourquoi la voilà vous le savez pas
alors si alors nous allons saler les
chacun comme ceci alors vous savez que
tandis youn helmand on ne salent
palaiseau sur le jaune en salles autour
ou dessous parce que chasse ou wii
dessous c'est à dire on salah avant de
casser la et ceci pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'effectivement chaque
petit grain de sel fait une tache
blanche sur le jaune d'oeuf et on pense
que ce n'est pas très joli sauvé sur
ceux ci on a faim se jette ici
alors là on met un tout petit peu de
poivre sur chacun des jaunes d'oeuf des
tirs 6 points je suis un peu monsieur et
là dessus je m'en vais faire circuler un
tout petit prix là vous faites à 302
paca series l'intention ou la face à ce
que le jour ne serait ce le blanc patron
se répartissent bien comme il faut
voilà et puis je vais laisser cuire
alors il est évident niamien dia il est
à côté de vous une assiette après un oui
peut-être bien alors si je veux ne peut
recouvrir comme ceux ci avaient quelque
chose comme 10 initialement
je me suis longuement
le tonton pourquoi alors voilà voilà le
genre de plats qui convient
merveilleusement à quelqu'un qui a très
faim vous m'avez confié quand vous étiez
seul c'était 5 et oui quand je suis seul
c'est le genre de cuisine que je peux
pas alors voyez vous une plaque comme ça
je fais ça pour moi tout seul vous avez
jugé que c'était bon pour toi et moi
avec moi j'ai volontiers volontiers nos
jeunes amis pourront faire ça si les
parents un jour du site d'aller faire
une excursion sans eux quand ils sont
tout ouïe alors j insiste beaucoup sur
le côté très nourrissants et extrêmement
reconstituant du genre de ce genre les
enfants ce qu'ils veulent c'est que ce
soit on marque on s'amusait mais aucun
pour moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
cuisine qui ne soient pas très bonne je
ne dis pas bonne ou très bonne
alors c'est d'abord très bon ensuite
c'est reconstituer ensuite est facile à
faire ensuite ces campings si tu sais
ces grandes terres un site a fait tout
ce à quoi vous laisse écrire ça combien
de passagers c'est cuit à partir de
maintenant on peut baisser le gaz alors
plus - - ça doit être ça veut dire
effectivement ça devrait dire que ça
diminue
voilà si si c'est vrai c'est fini alors
vous savez ça dans la poêle comme ça
comme ça où l'on sait pas très profond
et si jamais vous voulez pas le servir
dans la poêle ça peut glisser au large
quand même ça peut glisser à garder si
sa guise eh bien écoutez alors on va
dire parce qu'on dit bon appétit
vos invités à tous et je crois vraiment
que cette recette va vous plaire parce
que vous verrez c'est excellent je
faisais croire je n'avais pas goûté mais
c'est pas vrai on a fêté merci allemand
[Musique]